fou 3 2 1
eh bien oui j'ai bien je suis
et trois deux un eh bien oui julien je
suis actuellement dans la grande roue où
les gens se sont mobilisés puisque
au cat et bien oui je viens je suis
actuellement de remettre au pot
ce trio en quatre sets aiguë 3,4
souhaité souhaitez vous que 3,4
souhaitez vous que la grande route
seriez prêt vous mobiliser pour que la
grande roue on reste sur le banc la wii
se sont mobilisés par portée par
différents moyens éventuellement que
j'ai pas la porte et c'est pas
malheureux
rocap sauriez-vous près vos mobiles et
les
lesbiennes baissier
alors après ce départ du site pensez
vous seriez vous pas vos robes moi non
olala 3,4 après son départ du site
ouais
oh
le groupe
je suis désolé
ouais
bordeaux
là
après son
nous on est chez moi
eh bien merci
[Musique]